[Música]
y el año 47 antes de cristo
70.000 libros perdidos
el genio floreció allí en la biblioteca
de alejandría
tenemos por ejemplo a euclides el sujeto
que sistematizó la geometría de inicio
de traje
el hombre que definió las partes del
lenguaje y arquímides el gran genio la
mecánica antes de da vinci
como se debe en cuenta la genialidad
tenía un muy buen lugar donde florecer
de todos los libros que había sólo unos
cuantos pudieron salvarse y del resto
son los que han fragmentos que sirven de
tormento
de entre los libros recopilados se sabe
que existió una en particular escrito
por el astrónomo aristarco de samos
ahora este chavo fue el primero en
defender la teoría de que la tierra es
un planeta más que gira alrededor del
sol y que las estrellas están muy muy
alejadas chido no
hoy en día sabemos que la teoría es
cierta
pero con la destrucción de la biblioteca
de alejandría la humanidad tuvo que
esperar dos mil años para que dicha
teoría se descubriera
es decir que estamos atrasados en
conocimiento 2000 años
y ya no está tan sillón verdad
en un cuento escrito en 1941 jorge luís
borges e imaginó una biblioteca
universal en la que estarían todos los
libros producidos por el hombre obras
que se creían perdidas volúmenes que
explicaban los secretos del universo y
tratados que resolvían cualquier
problemática personal o mundial
algo así como lo que se tenía en la
biblioteca de alejandría en realidad
y si bien los libros que se tienen allí
eran meramente académicos la desgracia
de su destrucción y retroceso académico
que supuso sobre el hombre es un
buenísimo ejemplo de lo que pasa cuando
una sociedad no tiene libros
citando rodríguez more vivo en dos
mundos uno es un mundo de libros
y ya me siento hannah montanna yo
viviendo lo mejor de dos mundos
ya sea en serio
he recibido en la casa de los penes
destruir el retrato junto a dorian
dibuje una caja con un cordero dentro
para el principito
vi como áticos defendía los derechos de
un hombre negro junto scout y james
y tomé un triste tren junto a anna
karenina
es un mundo gratificante pero mi segundo
mundo es muy superior
recuerdo que cuando estábamos chiquitos
mi hermana y yo estábamos en mi cuarto
cuando un día llega a mi mamá cargando
unos plásticos amarillos gigantes bueno
en aquel entonces a mí se me hacían
gigantes y el punto es que nosotros no
sabíamos ni qué rollo pero nos pusimos a
armarlo y al final resultó ser un carro
de plástico amarillo muy grande fácil
cayenne adentro como unos 15 niños
y fue precisamente en este carro donde
mi amor por los libros se forjó
no sé quién labrador idea ni mamá pero
ella hizo de ese carro un santuario para
mí siempre siempre estaba lleno de
sábanas de cobijas de galletas y de
libros era me happy place el lugar feliz
con el tiempo pues crecí y una vía ni
cómo hacerle para entrar al carrito y
seguir leyendo así que seguí haciéndolo
pero pues ya así en el carrito
y después de un tiempo de haberme leído
todos los libros que estaban a mi
disposición llegué a la conclusión de
que cada uno de ellos sin importar su
género o el año en que habían sido
escritos me mostró un panorama muy
peculiar
los juegos de la política y su impacto
en la sociedad
ya sea que fuese de manera intencional o
no
cada libro que me leí me mostró un
reflejo de la sociedad en la que vivimos
una nitidez nunca antes vista lo que me
cayó como un baldazo de agua helada pues
pensé
como es posible que me haya venido
enterar de las diferencias entre los
sistemas económicos y sociales a través
de una obra de ficción
y cómo es posible que no supiera de la
revolución bolchevique es importantísimo
rol en la rusia que conocemos hoy en día
cómo
si algo he aprendido es que los libros
no somos tan problemáticas sociales y a
su vez panoramas de conflictos mundiales
y si bien siempre ha existido esta
vinculación constante del arte con la
problemática social es a través de la
literatura que ésta manifiesta con mayor
fuerza esta relación y un claro ejemplo
de ello
es lolita
siempre que viene alguien y me pregunta
y le dice de qué trata lolita mi
respuesta siempre suele ser
es un libro que trata la pedofilia pero
no es sobre pedofilia
y es quien si la historia sigue a juan
perón break un profesor de unos 40 años
de edad que dice estar enamorado de
lolita una niña de 12 que está dispuesto
a hacer lo que sea por tenerla
sí
es una premisa bastante escalofriante el
libro sin embargo no es pornográfico
como muchos lo pintaban
entonces porque fue prohibido en tantos
países sin y pornográfico es
y ahí el meollo del asunto verán resulta
que la introducción del libro el autor
personifica a un doctor llamado john rey
júnior quien en un punto de su elabora
introducción menciona otro doctor
llamado blanc watchmen quien afirma que
al menos 12 por ciento de los adultos
americanos disfrutan de la experiencia
especial de hong kong per
lo curioso de todo esto es que blanche
en francés es blanco por ello el white y
switch en alemán es negro por eso el
black ya que en realidad el autor
hablaba a manera de burla del doctor
white black man y hacía referencia al
reporte 15 y un reporte que habla de los
hábitos sexuales de los americanos de
a lo que voy con todo esto es que si
bien la idea de escribir lolita no era
nueva para nabókov no fue hasta que
experimento la vida americana en su
etapa adulta que lo hizo
por qué
por lo mismo porque en aquellos tiempos
hubo un auge en el comportamiento sexual
por parte de hombres y mujeres debido a
las contribuciones de freud y el reporte
15 que dieron pie a la creación
literaria es decir que todo lo escrito
en dicha novela no es más que el reflejo
de lo que la sociedad estaba viviendo
es por esto que lo lee que es un
clarísimo ejemplo de cómo es que los
libros nos muestran aspectos a mejorar
en la sociedad y aquí nos ilustran
problemáticas como por ejemplo la
pedofilia
el libro entonces a la par que un
planteamiento de los problemas del
hombre quiere por decirlo de alguna
manera la conciencia en la sociedad
provocando en ella un deseo de mejorarla
y así vemos que el libro no es sólo
entretenimiento sino que nos indica que
está ocurriendo allá afuera referente
una problemática y que cursos está
tomando la sociedad
la ausencia de libros nos hace menos
libres
al leer un inconscientemente se
cuestiona y razona y esto tras la
práctica es trasladado a nuestras vidas
cotidianas un pueblo que lea será un
pueblo libre porque será un pueblo con
ciudadanos que piensen y no hay barrera
cerradura ni cerrojo que puedas imponer
a la libertad de una mente
será un pueblo que se preocupe por el
prójimo que se involucre en proyectos de
desarrollo social tecnológico o
científico y que se inmiscuye en
conflictos que perjudiquen el desarrollo
del crecimiento del país
todo esto según un estudio del national
endowment for the ones
la encuesta nacional de lectura 2012
realizada por la fundación mexicana para
el fomento de lectura reveló que el 54
por ciento de los encuestados indicaron
no leer cotidianamente y que 35 por
ciento de ellos aseguró no haber leído
ni un solo libro en toda su vida
van y si esto no los asusta entonces tal
vez lo hagan saber que un estudio
llamado hábitos de lectura realizado por
la ocde
yl unesco méxico se posicionó en el
puesto 107 de 108 países con 2 libros
anuales por persona
y bueno si es que el problema no es
precisamente el no leer
el problema es lo que conlleva el no
hacerlo
retomando listo el principio de lo que
pasó con la biblioteca de alejandría y
contrastando la con nuestra actualidad
la frase de bradbury nos queda como
anillo al dedo
no hace falta quemar libros si el mundo
empieza a llenarse de gente que no lee
que no aprende que no sabe
el no leer genera pobreza desigualdad y
subdesarrollo
sin libros combinamos el país a la
mediocridad
hasta que no sepas que le debes exige a
tu gobierno hasta que no sepas
diferenciar entre desigualdades a que no
conozcas y sepas valer tus derechos no
habrá ningún avance de tipo social ni
económico puesto que se desconocerá lo
que se carece y lo que se debería de
tener
los libros están para eso para abrirte
los ojos y hacerte saber lo que te toca
dar y lo que te toca recibir
es como dijo orwell en su novela en 1984
hasta que no sean conscientes de su
fuerza no se revelarán y hasta después
de no haberse rebelado no serán
conscientes este es el problema
en comparación con otros países como
india con 10.7 de horas de lectura a la
semana y tailandia con 9.4 podemos
darnos cuenta muy fácilmente el largo
trayecto que nos falta por recorrer
deshagámonos de la creencia popular de
que los libros son solo para gente
inteligente los libros son para todos no
leemos para saber más
leemos para ignorar menos y más allá de
la idea que nos ha sido vendida sobre
cómo es que los libros enriquecen
nuestro vocabulario y demás honestamente
creo que el papel que desempeñan los
libros va mucho mucho más allá de todo
esto
por ejemplo los libros presentan o no
diversidad de personas
el hecho de que el 73.3 por ciento de
los personajes corresponden a personas
blancas y tan solo el 0.9 a personas
color nos indican posibles índices de
segregación y racismo
hablando de índices según el estudio de
cupertino southern boxer realizado por
la universidad de wisconsin madison tan
solo el 2.4 por ciento de los personajes
corresponden a personajes latinos y el
3.3 a personajes asiáticos
los libros también nos vuelven más
empáticos
verán cuando no lee no hace diferencia
alguna si el personaje es hombre o si es
mujer
si es blanco o si es negro
los dos esos que sacuden su vida sacuden
la tuya por igual
al leer uno no discrimina no divide
y por supuesto los libros nos vuelven
más humanos y sí sí ya sé suena muy
tonto lo sé
pero es verdad
han sido los libros y sus corrientes
filosóficas los encargados de hacerme
ver al ser humano en todo por su
potencial y tal es el caso del
personalismo
ahora el personalismo es una filosofía
que me gusta muchísimo porque una de sus
responsabilidades es ver al ser humano
en toda su profundidad y evitar las
relaciones yo ello con las personas
las relaciones yo ellos son las que se
dan entre una persona y un objeto
es decir que esta filosofía te pide que
no veas a las personas como un conjunto
de datos te pide que vivas en el
encuentro y que cuando puedas trates de
conocer la historia de los demás o que
al menos te des cuenta de que todos
están en una lucha en la que no sabes
nada
es por esto que los libros son el antes
y el después le pisan ya que este país
necesita buenos habla de problemáticas
sociales problemas geopolíticos y
valores en un intento de que seamos
nosotros los lectores quienes hagamos
algo al respecto para cambiar la
situación en la que estamos solo méxico
sabe cuánto ocupamos contar con una
sociedad lectora ahora más que nunca
pues tal y como josé fernández lo pone
si los pueblos no se ilustran si no se
vulgarizan sus derechos si el hombre no
conoce lo que sabe lo que puede lo que
se le debe nuevas frustraciones
sucederán a las antiguas y después de un
tiempo de deambular entre mil
incertidumbres será su suerte cambiar
tirano sin destruir la tiranía
partiendo de todo esto
hay una frase que dice que la historia
nos juzgará
no al prójimo no el vecino la historia
y resulta fascinante si lo piensan un
poco cómo es que cientos y cientos de
libros están escribiendo se ahorita
mismo allá afuera sobre todos nosotros
sobre lo que hacemos y lo que dejamos
hacer sobre cómo pensamos y cómo
actuamos desde este punto de vista los
escritores son algo parecido a los
cronistas
la historia por ende nos juzgará
porque todo lo que somos se ve reflejado
como destellos de luz sobre cristales
rotos y las generaciones por venir han
de saber en qué obramos mal tiene luchar
por un mejor mañana
irónicamente nosotros también somos esa
generación que tiene que luchar por un
mejor futuro que somos los jurados de
las generaciones pasadas
en tiempos como el nuestro donde la mala
información es la máxima norma leer
resulta un acto revolucionario
por eso cuando les pregunto sin libros
que tenemos la respuesta se resume en
cuatro palabras
ni pasado
mi futuro
[Aplausos]